you know i've got a serious question for
you guys
does this bucket make my trash look big
okay i promise that's the only bad joke
that i can think of right now for this
video but if i come up with more
i'll make sure i include them but what
we're talking about in this video here
is going to be sizing
attachments appropriately for your
machine all right so this is a 72 inch
heavy duty bucket
on a john deere sub compact tractor okay
and so what you're typically going to
see
on a 10 25 r you're gonna have a few
options you know like a 49 51 53 that
i've seen
the most common being a 49 and a 53 not
even sure they make the 51 anymore
but regardless this is a 72 inch heavy
duty bucket here
obviously it should hopefully look a
little bit disproportionate to the
machine itself and so
you know there's a common sense factor
to all of this and that's kind of the
overarching theme here but we'll go
ahead and get to the nitty gritty as
well and give you
several ways to look at this on how you
can size your
your attachments or your implements
appropriately to match the tractor
you know so something that's drastically
too small can be just as annoying and
frustrating and inefficient as something
that's drastically too large
yeah there may be certain applications
where something that's on the very small
side or on the very large side
would really come in handy but you know
the majority of the time
something like that isn't going to work
very well and it's going to make it a
worse experience for the operator
rather than getting something
appropriately sized and as usual if you
like what you see here consider hitting
that subscribe button right underneath
the video make sure to read through the
description as well a lot of helpful
links down there links to my website oh
yeah that's goodworkstractors.com i can
help you with a tractor like this
with an attachment for the front of the
back put together a whole package
i can help with financing and shipping
too okay so sometimes you really have a
size restriction that is going to
determine the size of attachment that
you want and so a good example of this
are folks that are going to be going
through the woods you know whether
they're creating a trail or maintaining
a trail or
they need to get back to food plots that
they have through the woods on the other
end of their
uh you know of their homestead and you
just
you can only fit much through there
right so it can be the same thing that
said versus an open station and a cab
tractor if you only have this
this tiny little area to get through you
want to have a small and compact of a
setup to navigate through the woods and
and i can tell you with first-hand
experience you know getting
some of those larger tractors with
larger attachments is definitely
a lot more of a pain in the butt than
navigating through the woods with a
smaller machine
so you look at these box blades here for
example you know these are going to be
great for great
uh those pass and and through your woods
and everything else but
you know if you can barely get your
tractor through there then why would you
want to have a bunch of extra width
hanging off either side that's
potentially going to hit
a stump or a tree that you didn't see or
it's clearing
you know brush instead of just
maintaining that pathway that you want
there so
that's another reason to kind of
consider the right size attachment for
yourself and just another angle to look
at it
for whatever reason snow pushers like
what you see here are going to be one of
those
um examples of an attachment that i get
a lot more
pushback on on the appropriate size
versus most other attachments
and i've got a hypothesis that it has
something to do with wanting to get
back out of the cold and into a warm
house as fast as possible
that makes a lot of sense but with snow
pushers what it really comes down to
is weight transitioned into traction you
know
by way of your tires making contact with
the ground and that's the struggle with
something like a snow pusher you know
and why
i am probably more on the conservative
side of not really recommending these
really
wide you know pushers that are two foot
wide or three foot wider than your
machine
although i get a lot of requests for
that and so not only is that attachment
that much wider meaning it's that much
more weight in itself
but it's also going to trap that much
more snow in here that you're also going
to have to push and it's just that
factor of
you know i wouldn't say it's your engine
that really has the problem with pushing
that snow but it's more of a factor of
the tractor the tires making contact
with the ground there
and having that traction to be able to
push that snow along
and so for that case i am typically
going to recommend a snow pusher for
example that is
roughly the width you know kind of like
the same way that your bucket is going
to be sized appropriately just
just a hair bigger than your machine
typically i'm going to do that with the
snow pusher as well there's certain
exceptions to the rule of course
but that's a pretty common one right
there okay so while these are facing up
these actually mow
laying down like this okay these are
brush hogs rotary cutters choppers
shredders
whatever it by whatever name you want to
but
i think we all know this goes on the
back of a tractor right here it's going
to be mowing fields
you know something that you you mow once
a month once a year once every couple
months something along those lines
and these are a really good example of
something for the back of the machine
that is typically
typically going to match up with the
width of the tractor as well so
over there you're going to see these
smaller guys these are for your sub
compacts i can get them in green i can
get them in gray
kind of like how you see this gray one
right here so they're all going to match
up with the machine i will sell these
for the subcompacts that are they're
four foot wide okay 48 inches wide which
is
pretty much matching the width of those
subcompacts you go to a 60 inch like
what you see right here
this is going to be more for your 3
series now even your 2 series though as
well which those aren't going to be 60
inches wide but they'll be within a few
inches
of overhang on either side which is
appropriate you know 72 inch for the 4
series or the
the large grand l series as well that
kind of thing so you kind of get the
drift
now there are some exceptions to this
rule we talked about the 2 series there
you know those are really what are they
52 53 inches wide and we're going to put
a 60 inch brush hog on there
but let's take an example here let's
talk about the john deere 3025e
okay this is a 25 horsepower tractor
okay it's going to be about 60 inches
wide
now an old rule of thumb an old rule of
thumb okay
is five pto horsepower per foot of
implement okay so five
so this is four foot wide over here so
you would want um
four times five so that's 20 horsepower
to be able to run a four foot
and this is five foot here okay so you'd
want 25
horsepower to run a 5 foot brush hog now
we're talking at the pto not at the
engine
so that makes a little bit of a
conundrum what are you going to do there
right
you're going to get some feedback online
about well hey this says it needs 30
horsepower in order to run this
attachment
it's only 25 horsepower at the engine
machine what's going on there so what
i'm going to do i'm going to run a 48
inch on there and not cover my tracks
or am i going to run a 60 inch here and
see what happens and roll the dice
don't take my word for this but i'd
encourage you to go ahead and look on
the forums that are out there like green
tractor talk
or the kubota ones as well or any you
know any of the tractor forms that are
out there
you're going to see this question has
been asked a lot already and
you know if you don't see it go ahead
ask it again you're going to get
opinions from folks that have already
done it but
what i'm typically going to do i'm going
to recommend the 60 inch for those and
i'm going to say that because the
majority of the time the majority of the
scenarios that you have
a 60 inch is going to be just fine it's
going to be
the one off situation or maybe the guy
who is going to be doing this
commercially
on new properties all the time with
different
varying levels of growth you know really
heavy dense
stem counts or you know six foot tall
grasses that are super thick and
could bog down anything there's going to
be certain scenarios where
this is not going to be the right one
but for most folks that are going to
maybe mow the same pasture the same
field
you know at their at their place at
their homestead you know a handful of
times a year
a 60 inch is going to be fine in a
situation like that now don't get me
wrong you're going to get different
opinions from that but this is just my
take on it
and i am typically on the conservative
side
you know so i had the sprayer home today
on my 1025r
hitting the lawn up getting some
pesticide on there getting some growth
regulator a little bit of fertilizer on
there too all sorts of stuff
but anyway it got me thinking you know
i'm always talking about ballast weight
and if you haven't done so yet make sure
you read the ballast weight guys you'll
watch the ballast weight videos that
i've done
very important to have that
counterweight in the backside of your
tractor when you're using your loader
it's a very big
safety issue and people have died by not
having the appropriate ballast waste so
you can't overstate the need for it but
it got me thinking you know i hate
paying
for dead weight it's the just the worst
thing you can do right but
sometimes you need to but what if has
anybody done this have
has anybody used a sprayer for ballast
weight you know of course this doesn't
weigh that much in and of itself but
you fill it full of water or you fill it
full of solution whatever it is that
you're going to be using on a regular
basis
and you have it there and it's not just
that dead weight but it's an actual tool
that's on the back side here so any
feedback on this anybody using those
pros and cons i'm just curious it kind
of came to me today i don't know what do
you guys think
as you can see this thing is quick hitch
compatible okay it's got a handheld
sprayer if you want to use it it is
boomless which i like i didn't want the
big booms that are hanging out here
so boomless it goes all the way up to 30
feet feet i think it is for the spraying
path or you can
taper it down to a lawn so you can do
food plots all sorts of stuff with it
this is a 55 gallon it's pto driven
everything you need
oh and if you're curious about one of
these ag spray sprayers right here i can
sell one to you as well
i can even ship it to you go to
goodworkstractors.com
okay so let's take another example what
we're staring at here is a six foot
72 inch wide landscape rig all right so
let's talk about
another way that you might want to
determine the proper width of your
attachment so something like this this
is like it's literally a rake it's just
kind of following along on the top of
the ground
raking up debris as you drive around so
there's not really a lot of
strain or stress being put on the
machine it's simply just following the
contour of the ground you're not trying
to
dig out roots or dig out earth really
even you know you're just simply
raking up the loose debris that's on top
of the surface of the ground
and so i don't really have any issue
recommending a 72
inch landscape rake for a john deere
1025r i think it's
a piece of cake for i don't think it's a
challenging job i don't think it's an
oversized attachment for it at all
i'm trying to wait out that beep there
in the background
so anyway the point being now if we're
talking a 72 inch rototiller for a john
deere 1025r and i keep talking about the
1025r it's just an example you can do
this with any model that you want
but i'm never going to recommend a 72
inch tiller
for a john deere 1025r so you can look
at it from the working width
aspect of it you can look at it from the
weight of the attachment itself the
1025r
whether it picks up 700 pounds on the
three-point i can't remember off the top
of my head
but a 72-inch tiller probably weighs 700
pounds
anyway so if it even lifts it off the
ground it's barely going to handle it
not to mention you know 700 pounds is
about half the weight 50
of the weight of the tractor itself and
so it's just going to throw it around
same thing with a 72 inch brush hog or
even a 60 inch brush hog
you know certain attachments weigh so
much compared to a landscape rake this
probably weighs a couple hundred pounds
where those huge attachments on the back
end they're simply gonna make
even if they do work they're gonna make
the operator so uncomfortable
it's gonna be just a a terrible
experience and if we get beyond that we
talk about the five pto horsepower
per foot of implement while you just
don't have it or anywhere
near it with a six foot tiller
let's look at it from another angle here
okay and so sometimes you're going to
have something for the front end
like pallet forks it could be something
for the back end too but we're just
going to use pallet forks as an example
here where
the width is just kind of it is what it
is right you know whether it's a light
duty frame like this or a heavy duty
frame or
anywhere in between or above and beyond
but the point being is that sometimes
you're more concerned with just the
actual weight of the
attachment of the implement versus the
width of it and that's the case with
something like this right here these are
really light duty forks okay i call them
the ultralight forks they're
they're rated for 900 pounds they're
perfect for subcompacts
honestly i've done a video lifting over
2000 pounds with these things they're
they're built very well okay but they
shaved out a lot of material here
they took off the headache rack there's
no steel up here the point being is that
it saves a lot of weight about 130
pounds away
they're great for smaller tractors that
don't have a lot of loader capacity to
begin with and i can get these for skid
steer quick attach i can get them for
custom attachment styles too that just
have to be ordered or the john deere
quick attach of course
you know or you can get the larger
frames as well okay but
you size them appropriately based on
your lift capacity for your machine that
you have
so that's another way to look at it but
the point being the last thing you want
to do
is have some huge heavy think about this
so a john deere 10 25 bar lifts what is
it 840 pounds to full height at the base
of the loader okay
this right here weighs 130 pounds less
but it still weighs
about 200 pounds just for a round number
so you think about that
you're lifting 200 pounds with your
loader or you get the bigger heavier
duty set and you're lifting 330 pounds
and we're talking just lifting up pallet
forks you haven't even started to do
actually
any work with it yet you're not lifting
anything besides just the pallet forks
themselves so
why would you not want to save as much
weight as you can with the pallet forks
you know with the tool
that way you can put it in to the work
that you want to get done
if you think about it you know when you
get a front end loader on your tractor
this is going to set the kind of the
table okay for
how you properly identify the size of
attachment but you get a front end
loader which has a bucket on it okay
now typically almost all of those
buckets unless you kind of custom
order it or go against the grain that
bucket is going to be
maybe the width of the tractor or
perhaps just a hair bigger you know
maybe two or three inches larger on
either side
so a four foot tractor like this again a
49 or a 53 inch bucket option
well this is about a 48 inch tractor
right so a 49 or 53 you're talking a
half an inch to
a couple of inches overhang on either
side just enough to cover the tracks
if we talk about belly mowers underneath
the machine as well something like a 10
25 r you're going to have a 54 inch or a
60 inch okay so
you have a couple options there and it
depends on the attachment right but you
can see there's nothing that's going to
be
you know eight foot wide attachment here
on a 10 25 r
nothing that's going to be a little
three foot belly mower on the on the
back or underneath the thing
you know you're not going to have a a
three foot snow blade on the front
because who wants something that doesn't
cover the tracks right
so if you get something that doesn't
cover the tracks well that can be
annoying for a couple of reasons right
so
for instance if it's a belly mower and
you're trying to mow along the borders
of your lawn and the edges of your lawn
that kind of thing and
and you have a mower that doesn't extend
uh beyond the tires then how the heck
are you supposed to get up there to it
same thing if it's a finish mower even
and the same thing can be said with a
bucket okay or an attachment that goes
in your front end like a snow pusher for
example if you're or a plow even if
you're pushing snow along
you know if you're driving over 10 inch
deep snow
instead of just plowing it along or
moving it out of the way well what good
is that
you at least need to have something
that's going to cover the width of your
machine
and if you think about it engineers
should be kind of designing tractors all
around you know from the footprint of it
to the hydraulic system and the engine
size and everything else to kind of work
together
with the attachments that's going to be
going to it because the tractor itself
isn't going to do a lot of work because
you have to have something on the front
underneath or on the back in order to
accomplish the work that you want to do
so it's that kind of thing that you
don't really even you don't even realize
when you're shopping for a new
attachment or you're shopping for a new
tractor and you think hey
it all kind of just came together here
and well i guess i don't have to worry
about it because it just
it just matches up with the width of the
tractor just a little bit more that's
just the way it is right
there's a lot of thought that goes into
that behind the scenes hey well i want
to thank you so much for watching you
know hopefully this was helpful
it's something that i'm asked all the
time and i want to make sure i get as
much of that
information out there things for you to
think about you know don't take what i
say
at face value you know these are just
ways to get your
only you can make the best decision for
yourself so it's just my opinion kind of
giving you
maybe steering you in the right
direction but it's up to you every
situation is unique so
if you like what you see here again
consider hitting that subscribe button
underneath the video make sure you read
through the description okay you can get
cool things
like this saw haul right here it's a
chainsaw carrier it just goes right
it just clamps right to the side of your
your loader arm here it's very cool okay
things like that in the description
below or at my amazon store always go to
goodworxtractors.com you'll see all my
latest tractors and attachments there
for sale as well
thanks again for stopping by until next
time stay safe we'll see you soon
you